Sullivan High School in Chicago is a school where communication isn't the easiest in normal times. Kids constantly have to pass their phones back and forth with Google Translate so they can understand each other.
芝加哥的沙利文高中在平时就是一个沟通并不容易的学校。孩子们必须不断地用谷歌翻译在手机上互相传递，才能理解彼此。
Over half the kids are immigrants or refugees. They come from close to 40 different countries. They speak over 35 different languages.
超过一半的孩子是移民或难民。他们来自近40个不同的国家，说着35种以上的不同语言。
That's Elly Fishman, a reporter who spent over three years there and wrote a book about the school called Refugee High. She returned there with one of our producers at the beginning of this school year and was there on the second day of school.
那是艾莉·费什曼，一位在那里花了三年多时间，并写了一本关于这所学校的书《难民高中》的记者。本学年开始时，她和我们的制片人之一回到了那里，并在开学第二天就在现场。
Kids are really nervous. They're not native English speakers. They don't know each other yet. So they're sitting among a bunch of strangers at this point. So there's a lot of anxiety and nerves.
孩子们非常紧张。他们的英语不是母语，彼此还不认识。所以此时此刻，他们坐在了一群陌生人中间。因此，这里充满了焦虑和紧张。
Sullivan High School is organized to make them feel at home. Each step at the staircase by the main entrance says welcome in a different language, private spaces for Muslim students to pray, shelves full of winter coats and backpacks for students who arrive with none, special curriculum and services tailored to them. This year, though, was the first time students were back in person since the pandemic, which posed some special challenges.
沙利文高中旨在让他们感到宾至如归。主入口楼梯的每一级台阶上都用不同的语言写着欢迎，有供穆斯林学生祈祷的私人空间，有为两手空空来到学校的学生准备的装满冬大衣和背包的架子，还有为他们量身定制的特殊课程和服务。然而，今年是疫情以来学生们首次重返学校面对面上课，这也带来了一些特殊的挑战。
Like, for instance, English teacher Annmarie Handley was going around the room student by student doing one of the most pedestrian beginning of school tasks-- filling out the seating chart with the basics. What country are they from? What do they speak besides English?
例如，英语老师安玛丽·汉德利正逐个学生地在教室里走动，做着开学初期最乏味的任务之一——填写座位表的基本信息。他们来自哪个国家？除了英语，他们还会说些什么？
Abdal? What languages do you speak?
阿卜杜勒？你会说什么语言？
I speak Arabic.
我说阿拉伯语。
What languages do you speak, sir?
先生，你会说什么语言？
OK. Now, you heard that student perfectly, because our producer was standing right next to him with a microphone just inches from his face. But that long pause, the fact that Ms. Handley asked him the question a second time, that's going to make a lot more sense if I just play you the sound from the microphone that was pinned to Ms. Handley's lapel. This is how she heard that interaction, more or less.
好了。现在，你听得非常清楚，因为我们的制片人就站在他身边，麦克风离他的脸只有几英寸。但是那个长长的停顿，以及汉德利老师第二次问他这个问题的事实，如果我播放别在汉德利老师翻领上的麦克风录下的声音，你们就会更明白了。这大致就是她听到那次互动的方式。
Abdal? What languages do you speak? What languages do you speak, sir?
阿卜杜勒？你会说什么语言？先生，你会说什么语言？
Yeah. She didn't hear him at all. Because she's way up at the front of the room stuck there typing into a computer. And there's an air purifier that they put in for COVID humming towards the back of the room. And there's an air conditioner running that's in the window just to her right. And most important, everybody is in a mask, muffling the students' voices, and making it so she cannot see anybody's mouth move.
是的。她根本没听见他在说什么。因为她被困在教室最前面打字，而且为了防范新冠病毒，他们在那儿放了一台空气净化器，在教室后面嗡嗡作响。就在她右手边的窗户里，还有一台空调在运行。最重要的是，每个人都戴着口罩，闷住了学生的声音，让她根本看不见任何人的嘴唇动。
Now, you can see how much I normally read lips.
现在，你们可以看到我通常有多依赖读唇语了。
She continues her questions.
她继续提问。
And what country were you born in?
你出生在哪个国家？
Egypt.
埃及。
Where?
哪里？
Egypt.
埃及。
Asia? What part of Asia?
亚洲？亚洲的哪个部分？
No, Egypt.
不，埃及。
Egypt. Cool.
埃及。酷。
So she keeps going around the room. And this keeps happening.
所以她继续在教室里走动。这种情况一直在发生。
Again, reporter Elly Fishman.
再次提醒，这是记者艾莉·费什曼。
It seemed to me, having spent a couple of years in the school before COVID, that it was just exponentially harder. And there was so much more miscommunication.
对我来说，在新冠疫情前在这所学校待了几年，我觉得这（沟通）简直难上加难。而且误解也多了很多。
All right. And then we have Claude. What languages do you speak?
好了。接下来是克劳德。你会说什么语言？
What say?
你说什么？
What languages do you speak?
你会说什么语言？
Kinyarwanda. Kinyarwanda.
卢旺达语。卢旺达语。
And what country were you born in?
你出生在哪个国家？
Congo.
刚果。
Rwanda.
卢旺达。
I said Congo.
我说的是刚果。
One more, table.
再问一个，桌子。
Dang.
该死。
Huh?
哈？
I said Congo.
我说的是刚果。
Congo.
刚果。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
Oh my gosh. I'm so sorry. I thought you said Rwanda. I will fix it.
天哪。真抱歉。我以为你说的是卢旺达。我会改过来的。
It's painful to listen to-- hearing these students give the teacher exactly what she's asking for. And she can't tell. Everybody is trying to connect. And they are not connecting. In the recording, you can hear Ms. Handley try to manage this awkwardness, save the students from the embarrassment, turn it all on herself.
听着这些太让人难受了——听到这些学生给老师提供了她所要求的确切信息，但她却听不出来。每个人都在试图建立联系，但他们却无法沟通。在录音中，你可以听到汉德利老师试图处理这种尴尬，挽救学生的难堪，把一切过错揽在自己身上。
Sorry. It's the air conditioner. It's not you guys. Your English is good. It's just this is right in my ear. And it's killing me.
抱歉。是空调的原因。不是你们。你们的英语很好。只是这声音就在我耳边。简直要了我的命。
When I reached Ms. Handley, she said, it is a lot harder to conduct this class without being able to see the kids' mouths. But for her, it really just feels like one more thing to deal with.
当我联系到汉德利老师时，她说，无法看到孩子们的嘴巴确实让上课变得困难多了。但对她来说，这感觉就像是又多了一件要处理的事情。
I think I worry more that the kid is getting frustrated, because especially at the beginning of the year, I need them to know that I'm listening and they can trust me. And I don't want them to feel as though I'm not listening or I don't care.
我想我更担心的是孩子会感到沮丧，因为特别是在学年初，我需要让他们知道我在听，他们可以信任我。我不希望他们觉得我没有在听，或者我不关心他们。
She says in the months since then, it's gotten a lot easier to communicate. The air conditioning is off. And more important, everybody is more comfortable with each other and with her, which means they're more comfortable speaking up, projecting, making themselves heard through the mask.
她说，从那以后的几个月里，沟通变得容易多了。空调关了。更重要的是，大家彼此之间以及与她相处得更融洽了，这意味着他们更愿意开口说话、大声表达，让别人能透过口罩听到他们的声音。
Communication is delicate. And if you don't get it right, it could be disastrous. They got through it here in Ms. Handley's class. But in our other stories today, it does not go so well. Like in one story, the future of democracy is at stake. In another, a mom tries to say something important to her own daughter so ineffectively.
沟通是很微妙的。如果你处理得不好，可能会导致灾难性的后果。在汉德利老师的课堂上，他们挺过来了。但在我们今天讲述的其他故事里，情况就不那么好了。比如在一个故事里，民主的未来岌岌可危。在另一个故事里，一位母亲试图对她自己的女儿说些重要的事情，却如此徒劳。
Also, Amelia Bedelia-- remember her-- who hears, but never understands. Where is she today? Here. From WBEZ Chicago, this is This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
还有，阿米莉亚·贝迪莉亚——还记得她吗——她听得见，但从不理解。她今天在哪里？在这里。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, Until The Cows Come Home. So this first story is about a man trying to communicate a thing, a very particular thing-- that the 2020 election in the state of Michigan was not stolen, that Joe Biden won. This is not an outcome this man is particularly happy about. He's a Republican, a state senator. But he says, this is the truth.
第一幕，直到母牛回家。第一个故事讲的是一个男人试图传达一件事，一件非常具体的事情——2020年密歇根州的大选并没有被窃取，乔·拜登赢了。这不是一个让这个男人特别开心的结果。他是一名共和党人，州参议员。但他坚持认为，这是事实。
The man's name is Ed McBroom. He chaired the official state committee that looked into all the claims of election fraud in Michigan. In the end, they wrote a report concluding that there was, quote, "no evidence of widespread or systematic fraud."
那个男人的名字叫埃德·麦克布鲁姆。他担任了官方州委员会的主席，调查了密歇根州所有关于选举舞弊的指控。最终，他们写了一份报告，结论是，引用：“没有证据表明存在广泛或系统的舞弊。”
Lots of his fellow Republicans do not accept this conclusion. And they are not shy about telling him that when they run into him. So Ed has been on a kind of personal campaign to talk to anybody who doubts him, as long as they want, in the hopes of being able to give them the facts they need to reach the same conclusion that he did. Our senior editor David Kestenbaum wondered if he was persuading anybody, and a few months ago went up to spend a day with Ed at the Upper Peninsula State Fair.
他的许多共和党同僚并不接受这个结论。当他们遇到他时，他们一点也不避讳地告诉他。所以埃德一直在进行一种个人的“竞选活动”，去和任何质疑他的人交谈，只要他们愿意，希望能提供他们需要的事实，让他们得出和他一样的结论。我们的高级编辑大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆想知道他是否说服了任何人，几个月前他去上半岛州博览会和埃德待了一天。
Ed promised, from out in the open for five minutes with my cows, somebody will come up and talk about the election. Here's David.
埃德承诺，只要在外面和我的奶牛待五分钟，就会有人上来谈论选举。这是大卫的报道。
I met Ed in the dairy barn at the state fair with his cows and his kids. That's kind of how he's known, the state senator with the cows and kids.
我在州博览会的奶牛棚里见到了埃德，他带着他的奶牛和孩子们。这就是他为人所知的方式，那位带着奶牛和孩子的州参议员。
Helen, Melody, Eddie, Carl, Esther--
海伦、梅洛迪、埃迪、卡尔、埃丝特——
These are the kids, not the cows. There are more.
这些是孩子，不是奶牛。还有更多。
Brita, Royal, Odell, Oriana, Kenny-Jack, Edith, Magnus, and Sayla. So there's 13 of them.
布丽塔、罗亚尔、奥德尔、奥里亚娜、肯尼-杰克、伊迪丝、马格努斯和塞拉。总共有13个。
You want to say a word about what that life is like? If you had to pick one word.
你想用一个词来描述这种生活是什么样的吗？如果你必须选一个词。
One word-- I think I'm going to say blessed, I guess. Blessed or hard-- blessed or hard.
一个词——我想我会说是“蒙福的”，我想。蒙福或艰苦——蒙福或艰苦。
Five of the kids are Ed's. The other eight were his brother's, who died three years ago and lived next door. So the families were always kind of one unit.
其中五个孩子是埃德的。另外八个是他三年前去世、住在隔壁的兄弟的孩子。所以这两个家庭一直就像一个整体。
There's one photo I saw on Ed's Facebook page of a kid who had put together some delightfully crazy outfit. But the thing that stood out to me was the stuff in the background of the photo, total chaos in the kitchen behind her. Ed's a farmer, a parent, and a state senator. He says sometimes, it's a bit much to handle.
我在埃德的脸书页面上看到一张照片，是一个孩子穿了一套令人愉悦的疯狂服装。但最吸引我的是照片背景里的东西，她身后的厨房简直是一片混乱。埃德是一个农民、家长和州参议员。他说，有时这确实难以应付。
I was interested in Ed, because honestly, it's alarming to me all the people who still believe the election was stolen. In one poll, a third of Americans and most Republicans. It's bad enough that we as a country seem completely divided on everything-- the climate, vaccines, immigration. But somehow, this idea that so many people look at the official election results certified by the states-- the method we have for settling all these disputes-- and say, that's a lie. That feels particularly unsettling.
我对埃德很感兴趣，因为老实说，对于所有仍然相信选举被窃取的人，这让我感到惊恐。在一项民意调查中，三分之一的美国人和大多数共和党人这样认为。我们这个国家在任何事情上似乎都彻底分裂了，这已经够糟糕了——气候、疫苗、移民。但不知何故，这么多人看着各州认证的官方选举结果——我们解决所有这些争端的方法——却说，那是谎言。这感觉特别令人不安。
And so here was Ed, this guy in the trenches, arguing for the facts in a way that few people are. I wanted to see how that was going and what the conversations were like. Ed ventures out of the dairy barn, where his cows are, past the fair games and the rides, to this indoor area where various vendors are set up, and where the Republican Party has a table.
所以埃德就在这里，这个身处战壕中的家伙，以很少有人使用的方式为事实进行辩论。我想看看进展如何，对话是什么样的。埃德走出奶牛所在的奶牛棚，经过博览会的游乐设施，来到这个室内区域，那里设有各种摊位，共和党也有一个桌子。
Hello, ma'am. Hi.
你好，夫人。嗨。
Hi. I was at Cityfest last week--
嗨。我上周在城市节时——
Oh.
哦。
People stop by who know him to catch up. A woman from the Gideon's Bible table across the way, comes over to say that they've been praying for him. And then this man and a woman come over. The first thing she says is, why aren't you having a full forensic audit?
认识他的人会停下来和他叙旧。街对面基甸圣经摊位的一位女士走过来，说他们一直在为他祈祷。然后，这个男人和一个女人走了过来。她说的第一句话是，你们为什么不进行全面的法医审计？
Forensic audit is the battle cry for people who want some external group to look at the ballots and everything, which for the record, have already been through a state-led, bipartisan audit in Michigan.
法医审计是那些想要外部组织查看选票及一切事物的人们的战斗口号，顺便说一下，这些东西在密歇根州已经经过了州领导的两党审计。
So why aren't you having a full forensic audit?
那么你们为什么不进行全面的法医审计？
You need one, badly. Those two vans that went in the FTC center in the middle of the night with nobody watching except the cameras-- and I saw it on Gateway Pundit. I know they went in there. And the little black car phone--
你们非常需要。那两辆在深夜进入联邦贸易委员会中心、除了摄像头外没人看守的货车——我在“盖特韦专家”网站上看到了。我知道他们进去了。还有那辆黑色的小车电话——
Well, nobody's denying that the vans came. It's just that we know what was in them--
嗯，没有人否认货车来了。只是我们知道里面装的是什么——
Bull--
胡扯——
Dan, stop.
丹，住口。
Well, I mean, the facts are--
嗯，我是说，事实是——
You do not know--
你根本不知道——
Well, sure we do.
嗯，当然我们知道。
Did you see every ballot that was in there and see that it was folded, if it was mail-in? Did you see that it was signed?
你看到里面的每一张选票了吗，如果是邮寄选票，你看到它是折叠的了吗？你看到它是签过字的吗？
So listen--
所以听着——
Did you check any of this?
你检查过这些吗？
So listen to the explanation, though. I mean, because--
所以听听解释，好吗？我是说，因为——
Ed's approach to these conversations is to answer whatever questions people have in detail, however long it takes, which is premised on an idea that I hope is true, but I kind of fear isn't. Basically, if you calmly present people with facts, they'll consider them.
埃德处理这些对话的方法是详细回答人们提出的任何问题，无论花费多长时间，这基于一个我希望是真的、但我又有点担心不是真的想法。基本上，如果你冷静地向人们展示事实，他们会考虑这些事实的。
The thing the man is asking Ed about is something that got a lot of attention online, a video of a van arriving at the convention center in Detroit after 3:00 in the morning with a bunch of ballots. Seemed suspicious to them.
那个人问埃德的事情是网上引起很多关注的事情，一段凌晨3点后一辆货车到达底特律会议中心、装有一堆选票的视频。对他们来说这看起来很可疑。
Ed lays out what his committee found. Those were ballots that had been placed in drop boxes, which he points out he's not a fan of drop boxes. But he says he looked into it. And the ballots were just going through the normal procedure, though the van didn't have any particular security.
埃德列出了他委员会发现的情况。那些是投入投递箱的选票，他指出他并不喜欢投递箱。但他说是他调查过了。选票只是经过了正常的程序，虽然那辆货车没有任何特别的安保。
So then the question to me is well, could somebody have done something to those ballots on the way there?
所以问题对我来说就是，嗯，有人在运送途中对那些选票做了手脚吗？
Could the driver have been in on it? Switched to a different van with fraudulent ballots? It would have been super hard, he tells them. The ballots would have to have been prepared in advance. The identifying numbers on the ballots and the addresses on them would have to match up with real voters who hadn't voted elsewhere.
司机可能参与其中了吗？换成了装有欺诈选票的另一辆车？他告诉他们，那将非常困难。选票必须提前准备好。选票上的识别码和地址必须与没有在其他地方投过票的真实选民相符。
And so that's a lot of crazy rigmarole. And in the end, what are they going to gain when they know that in Detroit, these absentee ballots are going to run 95% for Joe Biden?
所以那需要很多疯狂的繁琐程序。最终，当他们知道在底特律，这些缺席选票有95%会投给乔·拜登时，他们能得到什么？
No way.
没门。
They always do.
他们总是这样。
No way. They didn't the last election.
没门。上次选举他们没有这样。
Sure they did.
他们当然有。
Not 95%.
不是95%。
The absentee ballots in Detroit?
底特律的缺席选票？
Oh, absentee.
哦，缺席选票。
They tend to run very high for the Democrat side. Trump did better than any Republican for 70 years. And so--
它们往往会有极高比例投给民主党。特朗普的表现比70年来任何一位共和党人都好。所以——
Trump won Michigan, the guy said there. Ed told me in the days after the election, he started out with the same questions these two people have. There were lots of calls into his office after the election. And it wasn't like he automatically assumed there was fraud. But there was stuff he definitely felt deserved looking into.
那人说，特朗普赢了密歇根。埃德告诉我，在选举后的几天里，他开始时也和这两个人有同样的疑问。选举后他的办公室接到了很多电话。他并非自动假设存在舞弊。但确实有一些他觉得值得调查的事情。
Why am I seeing these news reports of chaos at a polling place? Why am I hearing about late night deliveries? Why did one county here flip so dramatically from one candidate to the other? Why are there rumors of overseas--
为什么我看到关于投票站混乱的新闻报道？为什么我听到关于深夜送货的消息？为什么这里的一个县从一个候选人倒向另一个候选人的转变如此剧烈？为什么会有海外的传言——
It was a long list. Ed thought, well, I can try to figure this stuff out. He heads the Michigan Senate Oversight committee. So he started an investigation.
那是一个很长的清单。埃德想，好吧，我可以试着弄明白这些事情。他是密歇根州参议院监督委员会的主席。所以他展开了调查。
Anyone who had anything to say could testify. The hearings went on for months. And Ed got way into the details. What if someone was given a Sharpie to mark their ballot and it bled through?
任何有话要说的人都可以作证。听证会持续了几个月。埃德深入研究了细节。如果有人拿到记号笔去标记选票，笔墨渗透了怎么办？
How does the election management software work? What happens if someone runs a bunch of ballots through the counter twice?
选举管理软件是如何工作的？如果有人把一堆选票在计数器上过了两次会发生什么？
That took time for me to learn. And then I had to verify that what I learned was accurate, because you don't want to just take one source as authoritative. I wanted to check others.
这花了我很长时间去学习。然后我必须验证我所学的是准确的，因为你不想只把一个来源当作权威。我想检查其他的。
It took way longer than he'd thought. He'd run down one theory. But then someone would say, well, what if it happened this way? So he'd look into that.
这花费的时间比他预想的要长得多。他会逐个驳斥一个理论。但然后会有人说，嗯，如果发生这种情况呢？所以他会去调查。
As the original ideas started to fall to the wayside, I did begin to grow less and less suspicious that I was going to find anything that was going to overturn the results of the election.
随着最初的想法开始被抛弃，我确实开始越来越不怀疑我会找到任何能够推翻选举结果的东西。
How much time did you spend looking into it do you think, all told?
总共算下来，你花了多少时间去调查？
Oh, I don't know. It was hundreds of hours.
哦，我不知道。那是数百个小时。
Ed put together a 35-page report with a 20-page appendix. He lays out each of the theories and really why they can't be true. When the report came out, both Trump and Obama tweeted about it. Actually, Trump issued a statement, since he'd been banned from Twitter.
埃德整理了一份35页的报告，外加20页的附录。他列出了每一个理论，并阐述了为什么它们不可能成立。报告出炉时，特朗普和奥巴马都发推文评论了它。事实上，特朗普发表了一份声明，因为他被推特封禁了。
Ed says he doesn't imagine either of the former presidents actually read it. Dan and Donna, that's their names, did not seem like they had read it.
埃德说，他不认为两位前总统真的读过它。丹和唐娜，那是他们的名字，看起来并不像是读过它。
What I want to tell you is that I know you have children. We have seven children. We have 17 grandchildren. And if we don't straighten this out now in 2021-- I don't like Biden. I like Trump. But that has nothing to do with it at all-- our children will never have a free election, if this communism, socialism crap--
我想告诉你的是，我知道你有孩子。我们有七个孩子。我们有17个孙辈。如果我们现在不在2021年把这件事弄清楚——我不喜欢拜登。我喜欢特朗普。但这根本无关紧要——我们的孩子将永远不会有自由的选举，如果这种共产主义、社会主义的垃圾——
What is so wrong with an audit?
审计到底有什么错？
Because-- you know, because listen.
因为——你知道，因为听着。
Then you could prove Biden won.
那你就可以证明拜登赢了。
What is the question you started with?
你一开始的问题是什么？
And he should be one--
而且他应该是那个——
That's the question you started with. So for one thing, the state has done two audits.
那是你一开始的问题。所以首先，州政府已经进行了两次审计。
Not thorough forensic ones like Arizona did.
不像亚利桑那州那样进行彻底的法医审计。
So I'll tell you--
所以我告诉你——
Again, Ed goes into all the details. The state had already done a thorough audit, where they recounted a sample of paper ballots by hand from all over the state.
再次重申，埃德深入到了所有细节。州政府已经进行了一次彻底的审计，他们手工重新计票了全州各地纸质选票的样本。
When we go and recount these precincts by hand, we don't find a single one of them to be out of line. Not one of them is out of line. And we did this audit--
当我们手工重新计票这些选区时，我们没有发现其中任何一个不合规。没有一个是不合规的。我们进行了这次审计——
So both--
所以两者——
Actually, a much more substantive audit than just that, because in that audit process, they don't just hand recount the ballots. But they're also checking the signatures. They're checking the applications. They're checking the paperwork for the testing. They're checking the test decks that go in.
实际上，这是一次比仅仅手工重新计票选票更实质性的审计，因为在那个审计过程中，他们不仅手工重新计票。他们还在检查签名。他们在检查申请。他们在检查测试的文书工作。他们在检查投入的测试堆。
Who is doing the checking?
是谁在检查？
So the clerk's office.
书记官办公室。
And are they all Democrats?
他们全都是民主党人吗？
No. All over the state. You have more Republican clerks than you have Democrat clerks all over the state. And most of the counties have multiple parties.
不是。全州各地都是。在全州范围内，共和党书记官比民主党书记官多。而且大多数县都有多个党派。
So you have your county clerk within your townships. You'll have Democrats and Republicans. And so these people are all looking at each other.
所以你在你的镇区里有你的县书记官。你会同时有民主党人和共和党人。所以这些人都在互相监督。
He doesn't seem to be making much headway. The problem Ed runs into all the time is that he'll carefully build this wall out of blocks of facts. But the person he's talking to will just pivot to another claim, which is exactly what happens next.
他似乎并没有取得多大进展。埃德总是遇到的问题是，他会小心翼翼地用事实砌成这堵墙。但与他交谈的人只会转向另一个说法，而这正是接下来发生的事情。
I'm just wondering what was wrong with doing a full audit?
我只是想知道，进行全面审计有什么问题？
Well, and I'm glad you asked. I mean--
嗯，很高兴你问了。我是说——
I mean, of the machines too.
我是说，对机器也一样。
Right.
对。
And did they change the batteries in the machines?
他们换了机器里的电池了吗？
So the machines that they changed the battery in--
所以他们更换电池的那些机器——
The idea here is that the batteries had been changed in some of the voting machines, causing them to erase data. Ed tells them, the machines with the batteries in them were just machines that marked ballots for people with disabilities, not ballot counting machines.
这里的想法是，一些投票机的电池被更换了，导致它们删除了数据。埃德告诉他们，那些带有电池的机器只是为残疾人标记选票的机器，不是计票机。
You sound so calm in a lot of this. Are you feeling calm? You've said these sentences so many times. Is there some part of you that is tired of it?
你在处理很多这些问题时听起来非常冷静。你感觉冷静吗？这些句子你已经说了无数遍。有没有哪部分是你觉得厌倦的？
There's a bit of a exhaustion, I suppose. But no. I mean, I feel very-- I don't know if it's compassionate or just passionate about helping people find the truth. I wanted the truth.
我想确实有一点精疲力竭。但没有。我是说，我觉得非常——我不知道这是同情还是仅仅是对帮助人们找到真相充满热情。我想要真相。
I looked hard. I have resources not every person has because of my position. I used them. Now, I want to give the benefit that I have found to other people.
我仔细看了。由于我的职位，我有其他人没有的资源。我使用了它们。现在，我希望把我的发现分享给其他人。
I feel like that's the perfect answer. I guess I'm asking if you actually always feel that way?
我觉得这是一个完美的答案。我猜我是想问你是不是真的总是那样感觉？
I would say 99% of the time.
我会说99%的时候都是。
Ed's been talking to this couple for about 25 minutes at this point. He doesn't seem to be moving them. But again, this is his strategy, answer every question they have.
埃德此时已经和这对夫妇谈了大约25分钟了。他似乎并没有动摇他们。但再说一次，这是他的策略，回答他们提出的每一个问题。
Then something happens though that throws a wrench in this whole thing. By now, a small crowd of people has gathered around. And one guy who's been watching jumps in. His first word-- baloney.
但随后发生了一件事，给这一切泼了一盆冷水。到现在，一小群人聚集在周围。一个一直在观看的家伙跳了出来。他的第一个词——胡扯。
--have proved themselves less than trustworthy.
——已经证明了自己不值得信任。
Baloney.
胡扯。
He tells Ed he doesn't understand why they can't have an independent audit. He's pretty insistent.
他告诉埃德，他不明白为什么他们不能进行独立的审计。他非常坚持。
Audits should be done for everything.
凡事都应该进行审计。
We've don a very substantial audit.
我们已经进行了非常实质性的审计。
We counted the same garbage that was there in the first place. OK, why were the elections in six states closed off at 3:00 in the morning and only to resume at 8:00, when that's never happened before?
我们重新计算的只是当初就在那里的同样的垃圾。好了，为什么六个州的选举在凌晨3点被封锁，直到8点才恢复，而这以前从未发生过？
It didn't happen in Michigan.
密歇根州没有发生这种情况。
It certainly did in Michigan.
密歇根州确实发生了。
Absolutely did not. That's a lie. People are lying to you. It didn't happen.
绝对没有。那是谎言。人们在对你撒谎。它没有发生。
Now Ed says, it's no longer just him having a conversation with this couple. It's like a live version of what happens on social media, and I think why things go so badly there. Ed's trying to have one conversation, and feels like he's maybe getting somewhere. And then this disruptor comes in from the side.
现在埃德说，这不再只是他和这对夫妇之间的对话了。这就像社交媒体上发生事情的直播版，我觉得这就是为什么那里进展如此糟糕的原因。埃德试图进行一次对话，并觉得可能有所进展。然后这个捣乱者从侧面切入。
And you still had Democrat and Republican poll workers there the whole time.
而且你整个期间都有民主党和共和党的投票工作人员在场。
Sounds like you convinced yourself, but I know what I saw. I can't get past the fact that there's no fraud to be seen. Really, Ed?
听起来你是说服了你自己，但我知道我看到了什么。我无法跨过没有舞弊这个事实。真的吗，埃德？
I didn't say that. The report doesn't--
我没那么说。报告没有——
Ed later learned that this guy-- he's the son of the couple who was talking to Ed. Ed doesn't convince any of them. Dan, the dad who'd come up with his wife at the beginning, who Ed hoped to make headway with said he just didn't think Ed had the expertise to evaluate the election. And what are you going to say to that?
埃德后来得知，这个家伙——他是和埃德交谈的那对夫妇的儿子。埃德没有说服他们中的任何一个。在开始时和妻子一起过来、埃德希望有所进展的父亲丹说，他只是认为埃德没有评估选举的专业知识。你对此有什么好说的？
A whole half hour of careful effort on Ed's part to lead them down a logical path is undercut in a sentence. He's trying, Dan said, I'll give him that. He's trying his best.
埃德花了整整半小时的小心努力来引导他们走上一条逻辑道路，却在一句话中被推翻了。他说，他正在尝试，我承认这一点。他在尽他最大的努力。
I watched Ed talk to one more woman. She came up after the others have gone. She was middle aged and full of questions. She brought up almost an exact list of things the others did-- the van in the middle of the night, dead people voting, whether the voting machines could have been hacked.
我看埃德又和一个女人谈了话。她在其他人离开后走上前来。她中年，充满了疑问。她提出了和别人几乎完全一样的清单——深夜的货车、死人投票、投票机是否可能被黑。
You're saying the modems, or the computers were not connected to the internet?
你是说，调制解调器，或者电脑没有连接到互联网？
The conversation feels like it's going exactly like the other conversation. They talk about the hacking possibility for a long time. But then they talk about Afghanistan and the price of electricity in the Upper Peninsula, which they agree on. It's expensive.
对话感觉和之前的对话一模一样。他们谈论了很久黑客的可能性。但随后他们谈论了阿富汗和上半岛的电价，他们对此达成了共识。太贵了。
This time, they don't get interrupted by anyone else. It's just two people talking at the state fair, which I think maybe more than Ed's laying out all the facts, is the reason why this might work. If he can put in enough time with someone, be with them long enough, they get a sense for him. There's a power in physically being in the same space as another person. They're real in a way that someone online or on TV isn't.
这次，他们没有被其他人打断。这只是州博览会上两个人的交谈，我想这可能比埃德罗列所有事实更重要，这就是为什么这可能有效的原因。如果他能花足够的时间陪伴某人，和他们在一起足够久，他们就会对那个人产生感觉。在物理空间上和另一个人在一起有一种力量。他们是真实的，不像网上或电视上的人。
Finally, they circle back to the election from so many months ago. Here's how the conversation ends.
最后，他们回到了几个月前的选举话题。对话是这样结束的。
If something comes up, I hope you will support an audit, forensic audit.
如果有任何事情出现，我希望你能支持审计，法医审计。
To look for any new compelling issue that we can't answer with the information we have-- I'm all ears to hear it. I'm curious too. I want answers.
为了寻找任何我们无法用现有信息回答的新令人信服的问题——我洗耳恭听。我也很好奇。我想要答案。
But all the issues they bring forward are either flagrantly impossible or issues that have already dealt with to a deep dive extent. And I just keep on asking them, show me where I'm wrong. And rather than do that, they just call me names or say I'm a bad person or paid off by China and shoot the messenger. And I'm like, please, shoot the message for me, because that would help me then go forward and find out what I did wrong.
但他们提出的所有问题要么是公然不可能的，要么是已经深入研究过的问题。而我只是不断地要求他们，指出我哪里错了。而他们没有那样做，只是给我贴标签，或者说我是坏人，或者被中国收买了，然后迁怒于送信人。而我就像，拜托，请对我传达的信息进行质疑，因为那将有助于我向前看，找出我哪里错了。
But I don't-- they don't do that. And it's frustrating because I'm just as curious as you are about it.
但我没有——他们没有那样做。这很令人沮丧，因为我和你一样对此感到好奇。
Just in talking to you and getting the opposite, you know--
只是和你交谈并得到相反的说法，你知道——
I appreciate you giving us an open ear to it. And certainly, if you have other questions, you hear something else, just call, message me, call the office.
我很感激你愿意敞开心扉倾听。当然，如果你还有其他问题，听到其他什么，就打电话、给我发消息、打给办公室。
Certainly. Well, it's good to hear from you.
当然。好吧，很高兴听到你的声音。
Thank you. Thanks for your time.
谢谢。谢谢你的时间。
Yep.
好的。
Can I ask, did it-- does it change anything for you?
能问一下吗，它——它对你有什么改变吗？
I'm going to go back and reread several things and re-listen to a few podcasts and stuff, and just--
我会回去重读几样东西，重新听一些播客之类的，然后只是——
I hope you'll look up the report.
我希望你会查阅那份报告。
Yeah, I think I will.
是的，我想我会的。
I'd appreciate it.
我会很感激的。
Yeah. Like you said, it's 58 pages. So I'll have to take the time.
是的。像你说的那样，它是58页。所以我得花点时间。
It was the furthest I saw him get that day.
这是那天我看到他取得的最远进展。
Ed tells me he has seen people change their minds. But usually, he learns it because they come back to him later, sometimes with follow-up questions. He wasn't surprised nobody switched sides right in front of us.
埃德告诉我，他确实看到过人们改变主意。但通常，他是因为他们稍后回来找他才得知的，有时是带着后续问题。没人就在我们面前倒戈，他并不惊讶。
You can't expect anybody to just disregard their long-held viewpoint or the narrative that they've accepted as being true. You can't expect them on the spot to really discard that. They need time to think.
你不能指望任何人直接无视他们长期持有的观点或他们已经接受为真实的叙事。你不能指望他们当场真正摒弃这些。他们需要时间去思考。
I pointed out that according to that national poll from earlier in the summer, something like 2/3 of Republicans, or people who lean Republican, believe Biden only won because of voter fraud. Ed says in his experience, it's fewer. But he humors me.
我指出，根据那个夏天早些时候的全国民意调查，大约三分之二的共和党人，或倾向共和党的人，认为拜登仅仅是因为选民舞弊才赢的。埃德说，根据他的经验，人数更少。但他顺着我的话说。
Can we do the math for a second?
我们能算一下数学吗？
Sure.
当然。
How many people are in your Senate district?
你的参议院选区有多少人？
Oh, around 270-ish, I would say.
哦，大约27万左右，我会说。
Thousand-- OK, how many of those lean Republican?
千——好的，其中有多少倾向共和党？
We go with half.
我们算一半吧。
That is 90,000 people would need to be convinced. If each conversation is 20 minutes, divide by 3, that's a number of hours.
那需要说服9万人。如果每次对话是20分钟，除以3，那是多少小时。
If you're trying to overwhelm you with the impracticalities of me one at a timing it, you don't have to. I'm already aware of that.
如果你是想用我一对一的做法不切实际来压倒我，你不必那样做。我已经意识到这一点了。
It comes out to 14 years. And that's if it works.
算出来是14年。那还得是如果奏效的话。
I was curious if that last woman had talked to had changed her mind at all, the one who had told him, it was nice to hear the other side and was maybe going to go read his report. So I reached out. She said over email she still believed there was election fraud in Michigan, enough to overturn the outcome, and that Ed McBroom was covering it up.
我很好奇那个和他交谈过的最后一个女人是否改变了主意，那个告诉他，很高兴听到另一方的声音、或许要回去读他的报告的人。所以我联系了她。她在电子邮件中说，她仍然相信密歇根州存在选民舞弊，足以推翻结果，而埃德·麦克布鲁姆正在掩盖它。
This is maybe the best case scenario for changing people's minds on this issue. Like, I do think if anyone could sway people it might be Ed, someone from their own party who also hadn't wanted Biden to win, who explains it all so patiently and clearly. And it's still so hard.
这也许是改变人们在这个问题上的想法的最佳情况了。我是说，我确实认为如果有人能说服人们，那可能是埃德，一个来自他们自己党派、也不希望拜登赢、能如此耐心和清晰地解释这一切的人。而且这仍然如此困难。
Ed reads a lot of American history. I asked him if he worried about the same thing I do. They were so divided. Neither side seems to be able to communicate with each other. No one seems willing to question what they think they know.
埃德读了很多美国历史。我问他是否像我一样担心。他们如此分裂。双方似乎都无法与对方沟通。似乎没有人愿意质疑他们自以为知道的事情。
I asked if he thought we were going off the rails this time. And if what we were going through might be fatal in some way. He said he didn't know. He said the social fabric has been stretched before, and we've gotten through it.
我问他是否认为我们这次要出轨了。以及我们正在经历的事情在某种程度上是否可能是致命的。他说他不知道。他说社会结构以前也曾被拉伸过，我们都挺过来了。
I hope that that's going to be the case now. But I think there's reasons to have some doubt about that too and to have some trepidation.
我希望现在也会是这样。但我觉得也有理由对此产生一些怀疑和不安。
That keeps me up at night, you know? It really does.
这让我彻夜难眠，你知道吗？真的。
I understand. I try not to let it worry me, because I firmly believe that we're in God's hands and the nation is in his hands and will trend in the direction that brings him the most glory.
我明白。我尽量不让它困扰我，因为我坚定地相信我们在上帝的手中，国家也在他的手中，并将向着能带给他最大荣耀的方向发展。
I didn't ask what someone was supposed to hold onto if they don't believe that. Ed's going to keep talking to people. There are lots of issues like this, he says. You just go person to person as long as it takes. That's the job.
如果一个人不相信这一点，我没问他应该坚持什么。埃德会继续和人们交谈。他说，有很多像这样的问题。你只要花多长时间就一个人一个人地去谈。这就是工作。
David Kestenbaum is senior editor of our show.
大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆是我们节目的高级编辑。
Act Two, How I Met My Mother. So one of the producers here at our show, Elna Baker, comes from a long line of passive aggressive communicators. By the way, they know this, they own it.
第二幕，我是如何遇见我母亲的。所以我们节目的一位制片人，埃尔娜·贝克，来自一个长期被动攻击型沟通者的家族。顺便说一句，他们知道这一点，他们也承认这一点。
When her grandmother wanted to get a message across, like don't leave change lying around, she put an article on the fridge saying, toddler chokes on penny. And then just leave it to everybody else to connect the dots.
当她祖母想要表达一个信息时，比如不要把零钱乱放，她会把一篇文章贴在冰箱上，写着“幼儿被硬币噎死”。然后就留给其他人去联系上下文了。
Elna's mother communicates in the same indirect way, which became a problem in the years after Elena left the church. Elna's family's Mormon. And her mom had some important things that she wanted to say to her. Here's Elna.
埃尔娜的母亲以同样间接的方式沟通，这在埃尔娜离开教会后的几年里成了一个问题。埃尔娜的家庭是摩门教徒。而她妈妈有一些想对她说的重要事情。这是埃尔娜。
This all started when I made a joke about me buying weed to my brother. Careful, he said. If mom were to hear that, she'd send an email to the whole family about how you're an addict. I laughed.
这一切始于我对兄弟开了一个关于我买大麻的玩笑。他轻声说，小心点。如果妈妈听说了，她会给全家发一封电子邮件，说你是个瘾君子。我笑了。
And then I was like, wait, what? That was way too specific. Did mom send an email to the whole family about me being an addict?
然后我就像，等等，什么？这也太具体了。妈妈是不是给全家发了关于我是瘾君子的电子邮件？
And he was like, uh, mm, nothing. Never mind, which could only mean one thing, she did. It took several rounds of questioning before I got the whole story.
他就像，嗯，没什么。算了吧，这只能意味着一件事，她确实发了。我问了几轮，才弄清了全部事实。
The email he was referencing, my mom had sent it 10 years ago. At the time, I was about to host a comedy show in New York, where me and a bunch of performers would play drinking games on stage. It was called The Drunk Show. The show is being promoted online.
他提到的那封邮件，是我妈妈10年前发的。当时，我正要在这个纽约主持一场喜剧秀，我和一群表演者会在舞台上玩喝酒游戏。它叫《醉酒秀》。节目正在网上宣传。
My mom, a devout Mormon, saw an article about it and freaked out. Mormons don't drink. It's against the religion.
我妈妈，一位虔诚的摩门教徒，看到了一篇关于它的文章，吓坏了。摩门教徒不喝酒。这违背了宗教。
And what I learned from my brother, years after the fact, is that my mom was so worried that I was doing this show, she sent an email to my family, my extended family-- uncles, cousins-- and family friends who I grew up with, like the Mitchells, the Coxes, Heidi, my middle school drama teacher.
而我从兄弟那里了解到，事后多年，我妈妈如此担心我在做这个节目，她给我的家人，我的大家庭——叔叔、表亲——以及我一起长大的家庭朋友，比如米切尔一家、考克斯一家、海蒂，我的中学戏剧老师，发了一封电子邮件。
Dear friends, it begins. I am writing because I am concerned about the direction Elna's life has turned. She is spiraling downward fast. My mom then explains to them that I'm doing this event called The Drunk Show. Then writes, I am very concerned. In our family, you are either an alcoholic or a Mormon. And I think she may be headed in the wrong direction.
“亲爱的朋友们”，它是这样开头的。我写信是因为我担心埃尔娜的生活方向已经改变。她正在快速螺旋式下滑。我妈妈然后向他们解释说我正在做这个叫《醉酒秀》的活动。然后写道，我非常担心。在我们的家庭里，你要么是酒鬼，要么是摩门教徒。我认为她可能走错了方向。
I don't know what I can do personally. She doesn't hear me. I'm going to interject here that I didn't hear her, because she never said anything to me about it.
我不知道我能亲自做什么。她听不进去我的话。我在这里插一句，我没有听她的，因为她从来没有跟我提过这件事。
In the email, she inserts a link to the article about The Drunk Show and then reveals her grand master plan. She's been commenting on the article under fake names, warning me not to do the show. Can everyone else please make up fake accounts and also comment? This way, I'll cancel the show. She ends, thanks, pray for us both, please.
在邮件里，她插入了那篇关于《醉酒秀》文章的链接，然后透露了她的宏伟计划。她一直在用假名在那篇文章下评论，警告我不要做这个节目。其他人能不能也注册假账户并也进行评论？这样，我就会取消节目。她最后写道，谢谢，请为我们俩祈祷。
When I read this email, I was mortified. I drink socially. I'm not an alcoholic. But since I'd never intercepted the email, I worried everyone who got it had thought this for years.
当我读到这封邮件时，我感到万分羞愧。我为了社交而喝酒。我不是酒鬼。但因为我从来没有截获过那封邮件，我担心所有收到它的人多年来都一直这样想。
I immediately clicked on the link to the article. At the bottom of the page, there were four comments from four different people trolling me, all clearly my mother. Her first fake character is Carol from the West Village who says, quote, "encouraging irresponsible drinking that could end in hospitalization of performers is an invitation to a lawsuit. Don't be idiots."
我立刻点击了那篇文章的链接。在页面底部，有来自四个不同人钓鱼式攻击我的评论，所有评论显然都是我母亲。她的第一个假角色是来自西村的卡罗尔，她说，引用：“鼓励不负责任的饮酒可能导致表演者住院，这是在邀请诉讼。别当白痴了。”
The three other comments escalate from there. Here's the weirdest part. She wrote all these comments while she was staying with me. She was in town the week of The Drunk Show. We slept in the same bed. But she didn't say a word to me about it.
其他三条评论从那里开始升级。这是最奇怪的部分。她在和我住在一起的时候写了所有这些评论。她在《醉酒秀》那一周在城里。我们睡在同一张床上。但她一个字也没跟我提。
As interventions go, it was the least successful one I've ever heard of or could imagine. No one else among the family or friends chimed in. And I, the target of the intervention, never knew what happened. I never heard of or read the comments online until my brother accidentally let it slip years later.
就干预措施而言，这是我听说过或能想象到的最不成功的一个。家人或朋友中没有人跟进。而我，干预的目标，从来不知道发生了什么。我从来没有听说过或在网上读过那些评论，直到我兄弟几年后不小心说漏了嘴。
Since I found out about this, I've wondered why my mom chose to communicate this message to me the way she did. But I've never asked her, because I figured it would just lead to a fight and no answers. But we're much closer now than we were when I did The Drunk Show. Why not try?
自从我发现了这件事，我就一直想知道为什么我妈妈选择用这种方式向我传达这个信息。但我从来没有问过她，因为我以为这只会导致一场争吵而没有答案。但我们现在比我做《醉酒秀》时亲近多了。为什么不试一试？
To my surprise, she agreed to talk about it, but on these conditions. Dad had to be there in case we needed mediation. I had to come home for Christmas in exchange. And most importantly, I could only do this story if she got to write the ending, which we'll get to later.
让我惊讶的是，她同意谈谈这件事，但有这些条件。爸爸必须在场，以防我们需要调解。作为交换，我必须回家过圣诞节。而且最重要的是，我只有在她能写结局的情况下才能做这个故事，我们稍后会讲到。
A talk for a second?
谈一下好吗？
Hi, Elna, how are you?
嗨，埃尔娜，你好吗？
Wow, mom you sound sexy. Wow, Mom.
哇，妈妈，你的声音听起来很性感。哇，妈妈。
I'm trying out a lower voice, because I think my voice is too screechy.
我在尝试一种更低沉的声音，因为我觉得我的声音太刺耳了。
Don't do that. Don't spend the whole interview not being yourself.
别那样。别花整个采访时间不做自己。
We started at the beginning. How did my mother decide that anonymous comments online would be the best way to reach me? She said my sister Julia told her about The Drunk Show.
我们从头开始。我母亲是如何决定网上的匿名评论是联系我的最好方式的？她说我姐姐朱莉告诉她关于《醉酒秀》的事。
So I'm laying there on the couch. I'm at your apartment, probably about 5:00 in the morning. And I'm stewing over this. I can't sleep, having haven't slept for hours.
所以我躺在沙发上。我在你的公寓，大约凌晨5点。我正在为这个心烦意乱。我睡不着，几个小时都没睡着。
And then I just had this little epiphany. I can put this on here in somebody else's voice. I don't have to use my own voice. And then maybe she'll take it seriously. You just need to hear it from New Yorkers.
然后我突然有了一个小小的顿悟。我可以以别人的声音把它放在上面。我不必用我自己的声音。然后也许她会认真对待。你只需要听到纽约人的意见。
Why?
为什么？
God, Elna, you're from New York. You live in New York. And you value their opinions.
天哪，埃尔娜，你来自纽约。你住在纽约。你很看重他们的意见。
More than yours?
比看重你的更看重？
Oh, absolutely, because I'm this fuddy duddy, old fashioned Mormon lady that doesn't know anything. You know, I'm like from 1950. I'm like June Cleaver.
哦，当然，因为我是那种老古板、过时的摩门教女士，什么都不知道。你知道，我就像来自1950年。我就像琼·克利弗。
Are you saying that you are like that or that I think-- you think--
你是说你就是那样，还是说我以为——你以为——
That's what I think you think I am, yeah.
那是我以为你以为我是那样的，是的。
Before things get too tense, my mom and I pull up the comments page together. The first thing I learned was how fleshed out these people were in my mom's mind, like Carol from the West Village, who warned that irresponsible drinking could lead to lawsuits.
在事情变得太紧张之前，我和妈妈一起打开了评论页面。我学到的第一件事是，这些人在我妈妈心中是多么丰满，比如来自西村的卡罗尔，她警告说不负责任的饮酒可能导致诉讼。
She's a lawyer, because that's the way a lawyer would say things, isn't it?
她是律师，因为那是律师会说话的方式，不是吗？
OK.
好的。
She's dealt with lawsuits that have involved drunk drivers or something with alcohol is involved, right?
她处理过涉及酒驾或涉及酒精的事情的诉讼，对吧？
To be clear, nowhere in the comments does it say Carol is a lawyer. For each entry, there's just a name and location, like Don from the Upper West Side.
澄清一下，评论里没有任何地方说卡罗尔是律师。对于每一条，只有一个名字和地点，比如来自上西区的唐。
Pretty ritzy area, right?
挺时髦的地区，对吧？
Who is done in your mind?
在你心目中唐是谁？
Don is a comedian.
唐是一个喜剧演员。
Oh, OK.
哦，好的。
Who's older. He used to do kind of the old-style comedy.
谁年纪更大。他过去做那种老派喜剧。
Again, reading the comments, you'd never know Don was a comedian.
再次重申，阅读评论，你永远不知道唐是喜剧演员。
Yeah, he's just disgusted with how comedy has evolved in the last 15 years or so.
是的，他只是对喜剧在过去15年左右的发展感到厌恶。
What does Don think about me doing this show?
唐对我做这个节目有什么看法？
He says comedy, where you are laughing at the performers and not with the performers is not comedy. It is tragedy. Is this really what NYC comedy is reduced to? Are you really not cleverer than this?
他说喜剧，当你是在嘲笑表演者而不是和表演者一起笑时，那不是喜剧。那是悲剧。这就是纽约喜剧最终变成了这样吗？你真的不比这更聪明吗？
Why did you think, like, Don saying this to me would reach me?
为什么你认为，唐对我这样说会联系到我？
Well, you love comedians. I mean, it's all about the comedy for you.
嗯，你热爱喜剧演员。我是说，这对你来说一切都是关于喜剧。
Mm-hm.
嗯哼。
So of course, if this is not going to be funny, then maybe we shouldn't do this.
所以当然，如果这不是好笑的，那么也许我们不应该做这个。
The next comment comes from the East Village, from a commenter named, Please.
下一条评论来自东村，来自一个叫“拜托”的评论者。
OK, so I'm thinking this is a policeman.
好的，所以我在想这是一个警察。
And his name is Please?
而他的名字叫拜托？
Yeah, Officer Please.
是的，警官拜托。
It, doesn't say Officer, mom. (LAUGHING) It just says Please.
它上面没写警官，妈妈。（笑）它只是写着拜托。
Why is this policeman writing me? Why is he so offended by this show?
为什么这个警察要写信给我？为什么他对这个节目如此被冒犯？
Well, he says 10 years after 9/11, and this is where New York is? Come on.
嗯，他说9/11事件10年后，这就是纽约的样子吗？拜托。
The show was on September 17.
演出是在9月17日。
I think this week of all weeks, we should all be a little more sensitive and full of introspection.
我想这周是所有周中最值得我们大家更加敏感和充满内省的一周。
OK. Can we just-- I think we can both agree that you went-- you went real big on this one.
好的。我们能只——我觉得我们可以达成共识，你做得——你在这一条上做得太大了。
I hit the 9/11 button
我按下了9/11按钮。
Her last comment is a straight-up Mormon talking point. Alcoholism, and all other addictions, take away freedom of choice. Seven minutes after she posted that, she sent the mass email. My mom said she went so hard because--
她最后一条评论是一个直截了当的摩门教谈话要点。酗酒，以及所有其他成瘾，夺走了选择的自由。在她发布那条评论七分钟后，她发了那封群发邮件。我妈妈说她做得这么绝是因为——
So I have two uncles who died of alcoholism poisoning. My uncle died at age 30. My other uncle came to my wedding completely drunk and ended up dead about two years later from alcoholism. Gary's grandfather died of alcoholism. So that's how I get there.
所以我有两个叔叔死于酒精中毒。我叔叔死于30岁。我另一个叔叔醉醺醺地来参加我的婚礼，大约两年后死于酗酒。加里的祖父死于酗酒。所以这就是我得出的结论。
It's not like it's a Mormon thing. It's an experience that has affected me. It affected my mother. She was just devastated over her brother and his alcoholism.
这不是像摩门教的事情。这是一个影响了我的经历。它影响了我母亲。她因为她兄弟和他的酗酒而深受打击。
Stopping The Drunk Show meant stopping me from becoming one of these people. My mom says she saw the promo photo of me sipping a drink on the page announcing the show and thought--
停止《醉酒秀》意味着阻止我成为这些人中的一员。我妈妈说她看到那张我在页面上啜饮饮料的宣传照宣布演出，心想——
Has she lost her mind? She has relatives who died of alcoholism. She's been taught since she was little girl to be careful around alcohol. Has she completely blocked out everything I've ever taught her?
她疯了吗？她有死于酗酒的亲戚。她从小就被教导要小心酒精。她完全屏蔽了所有我教过她的东西吗？
Did you ever consider just calling me?
你有没有考虑过直接给我打电话？
Elna, we've already been there. You don't hear me. You just don't hear me. It's just a joke. You have to hear it from somebody who you think is credible.
埃尔娜，我们已经谈过了。你听不进去。你就是听不进去。这只是个玩笑。你得从一个你认为可信的人那里听到。
Come on. Admit it, Elna, you know you would have just laughed. You would have called Kevin. You would have had a good laugh. And you would have had the show anyway.
拜托。承认吧，埃尔娜，你知道你只是会笑笑而已。你会给凯文打电话。你会大笑一场。而且无论如何你都会做那个演出。
But you didn't-- the thing--
但你没有——那件事——
Come on. Admit it. You know it. You know you would have rolled your eyes at me.
拜托。承认吧。你知道的。你知道你会对我翻白眼的。
But you didn't even try.
但你甚至没有尝试。
Elna, just tell me. What's the truth on your end?
埃尔娜，告诉我就行。你的真相是什么？
Well, I don't think I-- here's the thing. I think if you just told me not to do it, I would have done exactly what you're saying. But if we'd had a full conversation where we really talked-- like so for example, I didn't know until just now, until we've had this conversation-- like, I didn't really know that much about your family history with drinking.
嗯，我不觉得我——这是问题所在。我想如果你只是告诉我不要做它，我就会按照你说的做。但如果我们进行了一次充分的对话，我们真正交谈过——比如，我直到现在，直到我们谈话之前，我真的不太了解你的家庭饮酒史。
You don't talk about these unpleasant things. So that like when you're so against drinking, I think I did think it was just had to do with Mormonism and not that it had to do with really painful things you witnessed in your life, because you never told me about them.
你不谈这些不愉快的事情。所以当你如此反对饮酒时，我想我确实认为它只是和摩门教有关，而不是和你在生活中目睹的真正痛苦的事情有关，因为你从来没有告诉过我。
I'm sure I've said this statement before in your life. In our family, you're either Mormon or an--
我相信我以前在你生活中说过这个声明。在我们的家庭里，你要么是摩门教徒，要么是——
Alcoholic.
酒鬼。
--alcoholic, yeah. You heard that one before.
——酒鬼，是的。你以前听过那个。
Yeah, I just didn't believe it.
是的，我只是不相信。
She'd said this to me all my life, but I was missing the context. I've never met any of these family members who drank. I don't remember her ever mentioning any of these stories. I saw my mother as sheltered. Almost all her friends are Mormon. I just thought, she doesn't know what she's talking about, which was unfair.
她一生都这样对我说，但我错过了背景。我从来没有见过任何喝酒的家人。我不记得她提过任何这些故事。我看到的母亲是一个受到庇护的人。她所有的朋友几乎都是摩门教徒。我只是想，她不知道她在说什么，这是不公平的。
When I make a radio story, I listen to my interviews over and over again. And this time, something unusual started to happen. With each listen, my mother sounded less and less like my mother, like I stopped hearing her the way I usually do, rolling my eyes, getting defensive.
当我制作广播故事时，我会一遍又一遍地听我的采访。这一次，一些不寻常的事情开始发生。随着每次聆听，我母亲听起来越来越不像我母亲，就像我停止了通常那样听她说话，翻白眼，变得充满防御性。
And I actually started to hear what she had to say. This is the line that struck me the hardest.
我实际上开始听到她想说什么。这一行对我触动最大。
Elna, we've already been there. You don't hear me.
埃尔娜，我们已经谈过了。你听不进去。
She's right. And I can hear in her voice that this has been hurting her feelings for years. And that's my fault. I see why she thinks it's hopeless to talk to me about drinking, about anything.
她是正确的。我能听到她的声音，多年来这一直伤害着她的感情。那是我的错。我明白为什么她认为跟我谈论喝酒、谈论任何事情都是没有希望的。
I'm incredibly dismissive. That's my part in this. And her part, she was totally upfront about that. She didn't want to confront me about drinking, because she has so much trouble with confrontation of any kind with anyone, going back to when she was young.
我非常傲慢。这是我在这件事中的部分。而她的部分，她对此完全坦诚。她不想因为喝酒和我对质，因为她对任何人的任何对质都有很大困难，追溯到她年轻的时候。
I mean, as a little kid, I used to just admit fault to anything that happened in our family in order to get the confrontation to be over with.
我是说，作为一个小孩子，我过去常常承认我们家里发生的任何事情的过错，以结束对质。
I never understood before this conversation what that feels like for her. She panics, feels trapped, like she needs to run, tightness in her chest, which is what makes this conversation so hard.
在这次谈话之前，我从来不了解这对她来说是什么感觉。她会恐慌，感到被困，就像她需要逃跑，胸口紧绷，这就是这次谈话如此困难的原因。
This is what-- we're doing exactly what I hate to do.
这就是——我们正在做我最讨厌做的事情。
What?
什么？
Talk about conflict.
谈论冲突。
So what's happening to you when we do it?
那么当我们做这件事时，你身上发生了什么？
Well, see, I'm twiddling my thumbs, right? I'm feeling my neck turn to stone.
嗯，看，我正在玩弄我的大拇指，对吧？我觉得我的脖子变成了石头。
This cord, which is already coiled up, has been triple coiled, for the headphones.
这根电线，已经盘起来了，为了耳机，被盘了三圈。
So, yeah.
所以，是的。
Well, thank you for putting yourself in your most uncomfortable place.
嗯，谢谢你把你放在你最不舒服的地方。
Sure. You're welcome, Elna, anything for my daughter.
当然。不客气，埃尔娜，为了我的女儿什么都愿意做。
I knew what this meant. From the tone of her voice, it was time to stop. This was the most direct conversation I've ever had with my mother, and the longest real conversation we've ever had. She'd gone above and beyond and did something she did not enjoy for me. I could return the favor and call it a day.
我知道这意味着什么。从她声音的语调来看，是时候停止了。这是我和我母亲进行过的最直接的谈话，也是我们进行过的最长的真正谈话。她超越了自我，做了一些她不喜欢但为了我而做的事情。我可以礼尚往来，到此为止。
Well, folks, my ticket home for Christmas is booked. And now, for the ending my mother requested. It comes down to three words, she was right. Not about me spiraling downward fast, but about The Drunk Show.
好吧，各位，我回家的圣诞机票已经订好了。现在，为了我母亲要求的结局。归结为三个词，她是正确的。不是关于我快速螺旋式下滑，而是关于《醉酒秀》。
For the record, The Drunk Show was a disaster. I was the one who organized the drinking games. But because I'd only recently left the church, I was brand new to drinking. And all the penalties in the games were things like, take four shots of whiskey.
顺便说一句，《醉酒秀》是一场灾难。我是一个组织喝酒游戏的人。但因为我最近才离开教会，我对喝酒是新手。而游戏中所有的惩罚都是像，喝四杯威士忌这样的事情。
Things went off the rails quickly. A performer threw a chair at an audience member. I drunk dialed my ex from the stage. And the call went so badly that I started crying in front of the audience.
事情很快就失控了。一位表演者向观众扔了一把椅子。我在舞台上给前任打了醉酒电话。通话过程太糟糕了，以至于我在观众面前哭了起来。
Ira, who was in the show, got blackout drunk for the first time in his life, he said, and then threw up into a trash bag. And someone ended up in the hospital. My mom knew none of those details, of course.
艾拉，那个参加节目的人，他说这是他一生中第一次喝到断片，然后吐进了一个垃圾袋里。而且有人最终进了医院。我妈妈当然不知道那些细节。
But big picture, Carol from the West Village knew what she was talking about when she said, irresponsible drinking can lead to hospitalization. In other words, mom was right.
但从大局来看，西村的卡罗尔在说不负责任的饮酒可能导致住院时知道她在说什么。换句话说，妈妈是正确的。
Elna Baker is one of the producers of our show. Coming up, we hop on a Zoom with the most literal minded character in children's fiction. That's in a minute. From Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
埃尔娜·贝克是我们节目的制片人之一。接下来，我们将通过Zoom与儿童小说中最字面意思理解的角色交流。那就在一分钟后。来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Today's program--
《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目——
What we've got here is failure to communicate.
我们在这里拥有的是沟通失败。
Thank you, Cool Hand Luke. Today's show, we have people trying, sometimes saying the exact right words that you think would get across the meaning. And it does not work for all kinds of reasons. We have arrived at Act 3 of our show.
谢谢你，《铁窗喋血》。今天的节目，我们有人们在努力，有时说出你认为能传达意义的确切正确词汇。但这却因为各种原因行不通。我们已经到达了节目的第三幕。
Act Three, Amelia Bedelia Works From Home. So thinking about miscommunicated messages this week got a bunch of us here at our radio show remembering Amelia Bedelia. You know her? She's the main character in a set of kids books from the '60s that have just lived on about a housekeeper who takes any instruction way to literally.
第三幕，阿米莉亚·贝迪莉亚居家办公。所以这周思考关于沟通错误的讯息让我们这里的一群人想起了阿米莉亚·贝迪莉亚。你认识她吗？她是60年代一套儿童书中的主角，书里讲的是一位总是把任何指令按字面意思理解的管家，那些书一直很流行。
Like, the family asks Amelia Bedelia to draw the drapes. And then Amelia Bedelia pulls out a pen and paper and draws a picture of the family's curtains.
比如，家人让阿米莉亚·贝迪莉亚去画（拉拢）窗帘。然后阿米莉亚·贝迪莉亚拿出笔和纸，画了一幅家人窗帘的画。
These stories, of course, are so old fashioned. And we wondered what life might be like if Amelia Bedelia were around today. And we asked a writer, Hallie Cantor to think it through for us. Here is what Hallie came up with. It's read for us by actor Hannah Einbinder.
这些故事，当然，太老派了。我们想知道如果阿米莉亚·贝迪莉亚生活在今天会是什么样子。我们请一位作家，哈莉·坎托尔为我们考虑一下。这是哈莉想出来的。由演员汉娜·因宾德为我们朗读。
It was Amelia Bedelia's first day working from home. And she opened her laptop while still in her pajamas. My, what a nice situation, said Amelia Bedelia. I'm going to like working here.
这是阿米莉亚·贝迪莉亚居家办公的第一天。她穿着睡衣打开了笔记本电脑。哎呀，多好的情况啊，阿米莉亚·贝迪莉亚说。我会喜欢在这里工作的。
Amelia Bedelia's boss, Mrs. Rogers, had sent her an email with a list of instructions. Amelia Bedelia read, first thing in the morning, touch base with HR. That's odd, thought Amelia Bedelia. But she knew her job was to do what Mrs. Rogers wanted.
阿米莉亚·贝迪莉亚的老板，罗杰斯夫人，给她发了一封带有指令清单的电子邮件。阿米莉亚·贝迪莉亚读道，早晨的第一件事，去人力资源部（HR）触碰基地（建立联系）。真奇怪，阿米莉亚·贝迪莉亚想。但她知道她的工作是做罗杰斯夫人想要的。
So Amelia Bedelia got a pair of scissors and some paper, cut out the letters H and R and walked to the baseball field. She walked around the whole diamond and touched each base with the H and R. Done.
所以阿米莉亚·贝迪莉亚拿了一把剪刀和一些纸，剪出了字母H和R，走到了棒球场。她绕着整个钻石区走了一圈，用H和R触碰了每一个基地。完成了。
A text came in from Mrs. Rogers. Morning team, let's hop on the Zoom when you're ready. Amelia Bedelia joined the Zoom call and began jumping up and down. What are you doing, Amelia Bedelia, asked Mrs. Rogers? I'm hopping on the Zoom, of course, said Amelia Bedelia.
罗杰斯夫人发来了一条短信。早上好团队，准备好的话我们跳上Zoom（放大画面/跳上缩放）。阿米莉亚·贝迪莉亚参加了Zoom会议并开始跳上跳下。你在做什么，阿米莉亚·贝迪莉亚，罗杰斯夫人问？我正在跳上Zoom，当然，阿米莉亚·贝迪莉亚说。
Oh, OK, said Mrs. Rogers. You know what, Amelia Bedelia, we actually don't need you on this call after all. Why don't you just go order your lunch? You got it, said Amelia Bedelia.
哦，好的，罗杰斯夫人说。你知道吗，阿米莉亚·贝迪莉亚，我们实际上没必要让你参加这次通话。你为什么不去点你的午餐？你明白的，阿米莉亚·贝迪莉亚说。
Mrs. Rogers hadn't said what order to put her lunch in, so Amelia Bedelia decided to be an overachiever. First, she ordered her lunch by height. Then she ordered her lunch alphabetically, bread, cheese, chips, lettuce, tomato, turkey, water, perfect.
罗杰斯夫人没有说要以什么顺序安排午餐，所以阿米莉亚·贝迪莉亚决定要做得更好。首先，她按高度安排了午餐。然后她按字母顺序安排了午餐，面包、奶酪、薯片、生菜、番茄、火鸡、水，完美。
Amelia Bedelia checked her list from Mrs. Rogers again. Write some copy for the new home page. So Amelia Bedelia sat at her laptop and typed the words, the new home page, 50 times in a row. Writing some copy sure was easy.
阿米莉亚·贝迪莉亚再次查看了罗杰斯夫人的清单。为新主页写一些文案（复制品）。所以阿米莉亚·贝迪莉亚坐在笔记本电脑前，连续打出了“新主页”这个词50遍。写一些文案确实很容易。
Soon after she had sent in her work, Mrs. Rogers called, sounding angry. Amelia Bedelia, I hired you to increase our brand engagement, not to waste my time. You're fired.
在她交上工作后不久，罗杰斯夫人打来电话，听起来很生气。阿米莉亚·贝迪莉亚，我雇你是为了增加我们的品牌参与度，不是为了浪费我的时间。你被解雇了。
Amelia Bedelia was stunned. When she told her roommate Alexis what happened, Alexis asked how she was going to make rent. I can't think about putting on a revival of a 1996 musical right now, Alexis, said Amelia Bedelia. I just lost my job.
阿米莉亚·贝迪莉亚惊呆了。当她告诉室友亚历克西斯发生了什么事时，亚历克西斯问她打算怎么支付房租。我没法考虑现在安排1996年音乐剧的复演，亚历克西斯，阿米莉亚·贝迪莉亚说。我刚刚失去了工作。
Then she heard the sound of hammering and frustrated cursing from outside. She went to investigate and saw a man trying to construct something out of wood and nails. Amelia Bedelia introduced herself. The man, Alfonso Badonzo, explained that his boss had asked him to build a deck for a presentation tomorrow.
然后她听到外面传来锤击声和沮丧的咒骂声。她去调查，看到一个男人试图用木头和钉子建造某种东西。阿米莉亚·贝迪莉亚介绍了自己。那个男人，阿方索·巴东佐，解释说他的老板让他为一个明天的演讲建一个甲板（平台）。
I've been working for hours, but I just don't understand how he expects me to build a deck in one day. The same sorts of things have been happening to me, Amelia Bedelia said. Then Amelia Bedelia had an idea.
我已经工作了几个小时了，但我就是不明白他怎么期望我在一天之内建一个甲板。我身上也发生了同样的事情，阿米莉亚·贝迪莉亚说。然后阿米莉亚·贝迪莉亚有了一个主意。
She knelt in front of Alfonso Badonzo and proposed marriage. Alfonso Badonzo accepted immediately. Amelia Bedelia was thrilled. Now that I've increased engagement, Mrs. Rogers will definitely give me my job back. Also, can I move in with you? I'm pretty sure my roommate is changing the locks.
她跪在阿方索·巴东佐面前，向他求婚。阿方索·巴东佐立刻接受了。阿米莉亚·贝迪莉亚非常激动。既然我已经增加了参与度，罗杰斯夫人一定会让我复职的。另外，我可以搬去和你住吗？我敢肯定我的室友正在更换锁。
Why do the locks need changing, Alfonso Badonzo asked, were their clothes dirty? Amelia Bedelia looked at him, her soulmate.
为什么锁需要更换，阿方索·巴东佐问，他们的衣服脏了吗？阿米莉亚·贝迪莉亚看着他，她的灵魂伴侣。
Hannah Enbinder, reading a story by Hallie Cantor. Hallie's the main writer of Magical Girl Friendship Squad. Her website, halliecantor.com. You can hear and see more of Hannah on HBO's Hacks.
汉娜·因宾德，朗读哈莉·坎托尔的故事。哈莉是《魔法少女友谊小队》的主要作家。她的网站，halliecantor.com。你可以在HBO的《绝望写手》中听到和看到更多汉娜的表现。
Act Four, The Importance of Meeting Earnest. So we end today's program with one final act of miscommunication, a dad who has a crucial bit of information that everyone in his family would want to know that he somehow neglects to mention for over a half century. Jeanne Darst tells what happened.
第四幕，与恩尼斯特见面的重要性。我们今天节目以最后一个沟通错误作为结尾，一位父亲掌握着家人每个人都想知道的一个关键信息，而他却不知何故在半个多世纪里忽略了提及。让·达斯特讲述了发生的事情。
I was the last one to meet Ernest, because I was the last one to find out Ernest existed. Here's what happened. My sister, Amy, stopped by my sister Liz's house to discuss a very urgent matter, an outlandish story that my father was hitting on a priest at the Westport Catholic church.
我是最后一个遇见恩尼斯特的人，因为我是最后一个发现恩尼斯特存在的人。这是发生的事情。我姐姐，艾米，停在我姐姐利兹的房子里讨论一件非常紧急的事情，一个关于我父亲在韦斯特波特天主教教堂调戏一位神父的离奇故事。
Liz cut her off. Dad is not gay, but if he was, nobody cares. Amy shot back, well, you don't know dad as well as you think you do. He has a son in New Orleans.
利兹打断了她。爸爸不是同性恋，但即使他是，也没人关心。艾米反击说，好吧，你并不像你认为的那样了解爸爸。他在新奥尔良有个儿子。
Liz yells, wait! What? Amy says, google "Ernie The Attorney." The second Liz tells me this of course, I flip open my laptop and google "Ernie The Attorney." And Ernie The Attorney's face, which is identical to my father's face, pops up off the screen and attaches itself to my eyeballs.
利兹大喊，等等！什么？艾米说，去谷歌搜“恩尼律师”。当然，利兹告诉我的那一刻，我打开笔记本电脑，谷歌搜“恩尼律师”。而恩尼律师的脸，和我父亲的脸一模一样，从屏幕上跳出来并粘在了我的眼球上。
He looks more like my father than any of us. He looks more like my father than my father. Liz calls my dad. Hey, Dad, Amy said she found you googling this guy late at night and that he's your son-- that you have a son in New Orleans.
他看起来比我们任何人都像我父亲。他看起来比我父亲更像我父亲。利兹打电话给我爸爸。嘿，爸爸，艾米说她发现你深夜谷歌这个家伙，而且他是你的儿子——你有在纽奥良的儿子。
My dad says, you mean, the doctor? Liz yells, there's a doctor too? Oh, sorry, I meant the attorney. Oh, well, that's true.
我爸爸说，你是说，那个医生？利兹大喊，还有一个医生？哦，抱歉，我是指律师。哦，好吧，那是真的。
He acts like he wasn't keeping this from us for 62 years. We just weren't asking the right questions. He never told anyone I'm sure, because he knew my mom would never stop bringing it up.
他的行为就像他62年来没对我们隐瞒这件事一样。我们只是没有问正确的问题。我相信他从来没有告诉过任何人，因为他知道我妈妈会永远提起它。
And then he, rather matter-of-factly, tells Liz that when he was a 24-year-old reporter in New Orleans, he met a 22-year-old married Panamanian woman named Raquel Elena Lefevre, he called her Raqui. And they had an affair.
然后他相当不动声色地告诉利兹，当他是纽奥良一个24岁的记者时，他认识了一个叫拉奎尔·埃琳娜·勒费弗的22岁已婚巴拿马女人，他叫她拉奎。他们有了婚外情。
Her husband, a Swedish psychoanalyst who was a decade older, was infertile and didn't tell her that when they got married. He was also a philanderer. Everyone in this story I should just say, men, women, everyone in this story is a philanderer.
她的丈夫，一位大十岁的瑞典心理分析家，不育并且在他们结婚时没有告诉她。他也是个花花公子。在这个故事里的每个人我都应该说明一下，男人、女人，在这个故事里的每个人都是花花公子。
So initially, Raqui is just looking to conceive. But she and my father fall in love. Then Raqui's father, a Panamanian businessman, comes to the States. And the three of them have lunch-- her father, my father, and a newly pregnant Raqui. She presents my father to ask if she can leave the Swedish psychoanalyst.
所以起初，拉奎只是想要受孕。但她和我父亲坠入爱河。然后拉奎的父亲，一位巴拿马商人，来到美国。他们三个人吃了午餐——她的父亲、我的父亲和一个刚怀孕的拉奎。她向我父亲提出请求，问她是否可以离开那个瑞典心理分析家。
Her father says, no, you're staying put. Catholicism playing some part, but perhaps, my father making $56 a week being another part. So my father feels the child is in a marriage, has a father, and there's nothing he can do. He moves back to St. Louis, marries my mother and has us four girls. And doesn't ever interact with this truth again. How does someone do that?
她的父亲说，不，你待着别动。天主教在其中起了一些作用，但也许，我父亲每周赚56美元是另一个部分。所以父亲觉得那个孩子在婚姻里，有父亲，而且他什么也做不了。他搬回了圣路易斯，娶了我母亲，有了我们四个女儿。并且再也没有与这个真相产生过交互。一个人怎么能做到那样？
I call my dad the next day. I've been freaking out. My friends are freaking out. It's like the March girls have discovered they have a brother.
第二天我给爸爸打电话。我一直心烦意乱。我的朋友们都心烦意乱。就像马奇家的女孩们发现她们有个兄弟一样。
When I get him on the phone he says, now, listen, Jean-Joe, I put Lizabetha about 80% chance of being mine. But you, I got to put your numbers a lot lower than that. But really, the both of you ought to get DNA tests, because your mother was wild and she was beautiful, and of course, she drank too much.
当我在电话里让他说的时候，他说，现在，听着，让-乔，我给利兹大约80%的可能性是我的。但你，我得把你的数字调低得多。但真的，你们两个都应该去做DNA测试，因为你母亲很野，而且她很漂亮，当然，她喝得太多了。
Dad, what? I get off the phone and remember, I had done a 23andMe a few years back. So I go to the site. Suddenly, I'm on a side project of proving my father is actually my father. And I click a link I'd never seen before-- view all DNA relatives.
爸爸，什么？我挂断电话并记得，几年前我做过一次23andMe。所以我去了那个网站。突然，我在做一个证明我父亲确实是我父亲的副项目。我点击了一个我以前从未见过的链接——查看所有DNA亲属。
And Ernie the Attorney's face pops up off the screen again, along with his three kids identified as my half nieces and nephew. I have no idea why confirming Ernest as my brother confirms my father is my father, but it just does. The question now is, do we contact this sweet-looking, innocent 62-year-old man and overturn everything he believes about his identity?
而恩尼律师的脸再次从屏幕上跳了出来，连同他的三个被确认为我半侄女和侄子的孩子。我不知道为什么确认恩尼是我的兄弟证实了我的父亲是我的父亲，但这确实是这样。现在的问题是，我们要联系这个看起来甜美、无辜的62岁男人并推翻他所相信的关于他身份的一切吗？
We decide to go for it. And I email him saying, I believe you're my half brother. And then Liz and I act like crazy people for the next 24 hours until he emails back. And the next day, we're meeting for the first time on Zoom.
我们决定去做。我发邮件给他，说，我相信你是我的同父异母兄弟。然后利兹和我就像疯子一样在接下来的24小时里等待他回信。第二天，我们第一次通过Zoom见面。
He tells us that his parents got divorced when he was five and there was a big custody battle. And when he was 17, his mother, in a fit of boozy despair, blurted out that his father was not his father, that his father was a man named Stephen Darst, who is a writer from St. Louis.
他告诉我们，他的父母在他五岁时离婚了，有一场大的监护权争夺战。在他17岁时，他的母亲，在一次酒醉的绝望中，脱口而出他的父亲不是他的父亲，他的父亲是一个叫斯蒂芬·达斯特的人，一个来自圣路易斯的作家。
And then Ernest, raised by a psychoanalyst, says he considered the information and had no idea what to do with it, and promptly repressed it. And no one ever talked about it after that day. He says he never thought of it again until I emailed him.
然后恩尼，由一位心理分析家抚养长大，说他考虑了这些信息，不知道该怎么做，并迅速压制了它。从那天以后再没有人谈论过它。他说他从来没再想过这件事，直到我给他发了邮件。
One weird coincidence, he tells us that for years, his father dated a woman who lived in Bronxville, New York. And they would go visit her all the time in Bronxville, where we lived. We could have run into him at the A&P.
一个奇怪的巧合，他告诉我们多年来，他的父亲和一个住在纽约布朗克斯维尔的女人约会。他们总是去布朗克斯维尔看望她，而我们就住在那里。我们本可能在A&P超市遇到他。
The following week, Liz goes to my dad's and helps him get on a Zoom with everybody. And suddenly, I'm watching my 87-year-old father meet his 62-year-old son. And I'm seeing Ernie get information about his mother from my dad, who remembers absolutely every detail about everything-- the restaurants they went to, how she called her dog Daisy "Desi" in her accent, how every time they would part they would walk about 100 feet in opposite directions, and my father would turn around and yell, hey, Raqui.
接下来的一周，利兹去了我爸爸那里，帮他和一个Zoom和所有人连上。突然，我看着我87岁的父亲遇见他62岁的儿子。我看着恩尼从我爸爸那里得到关于他母亲的信息，爸爸对一切细节都记忆犹新——他们去过的餐厅，她用口音把她的狗戴西叫成“德西”，每次他们分开时他们都会向相反方向走大约100英尺，然后我父亲会转过身大喊，嘿，拉奎。
And when she turned around, my dad would make this embracing gesture with his arms. Earnest says to me, it's amazing to talk about my mom with a man who loved her, which Swedish dad did not. Ernie sends us pictures of Raqui. She looks like a Panamanian Sophia Loren. In fact, Raqui was a lot like my mom. She was beautiful, sort of fancy. Her grandfather was the president of Panama.
当她转身时，爸爸会做这种用双臂拥抱的姿势。恩尼对我说，和爱过她的人谈论我的妈妈真是太神奇了，而瑞典爸爸却没有。恩尼发给我们拉奎的照片。她看起来像巴拿马的索菲亚·罗兰。事实上，拉奎和我的妈妈很像。她很漂亮，有点时髦。她的祖父是巴拿马总统。
She drank too much, smoked too much, and had major depression. My dad definitely has a type. The whole thing with Ernie was fun and exciting. My sisters and I were talking on the phone all the time, you know, the three of us that are currently speaking to each other.
她喝得太多，抽得太多，并且有严重的抑郁症。爸爸确实有喜欢的人选。关于恩尼的整件事有趣又令人兴奋。我和姐妹们一直都在打电话，你知道，我们三个目前还在和对方说话的姐妹。
But also what made it so exciting was how together an "adulty" he was. He sent me a card with a watercolor drawing of his house in New Orleans on the front, which when I got it, I was like, oh, my God, he's got stationery. None of us girls have stationery.
但同样让它如此令人兴奋的是他表现得多么得体和“成人”。他寄给我一张卡片，正面有他纽奥良房子的水彩画，当我拿到它时，我心想，哦，我的天，他有信笺。我们这些女孩都没有信笺。
He's decent and caring and even-tempered. He asks me how I am and how I feel about this or that. And then he waits for me to answer.
他得体、有爱心且脾气温和。他问我怎么样，我对这个或那个感觉如何。然后他等着我回答。
He made me Raqui's Panamanian Christmas cookies. He was kind, not something in great supply in my showboating drinking, dancy family. Kind is what my mother would have said about people who couldn't throw a decent cocktail party. People who just weren't with it.
他给我做了拉奎的巴拿马圣诞饼干。他很善良，这在我那个炫耀、喝酒、跳舞的家庭里并不多见。善良是妈妈会用在那些不能办一场体面的鸡尾酒会的人身上的词。那些只是没跟上节奏的人。
I started to feel like this was our chance to be a bona fide loving family. So Liz and I had a plan to throw an 88th birthday party for our dad and lure Ernie and his wife Donna to New York for it. We never actually said this to each other, but the big question in the air was, is this going to be a real relationship? Is this just going to be a few Zoom calls, or are we going to get together at holidays with our kids for years to come?
我开始觉得这是我们成为真正相亲相爱家庭的机会。所以利兹和我计划为爸爸举办88岁生日派对，并引诱恩尼和他的妻子唐娜来纽约参加。我们从来没对彼此真正说过，但空气中巨大的问题是，这会是真正的关系吗？这只是几次Zoom通话，还是我们未来几年会在节日里带着孩子聚在一起？
We'd get together in person and Liz's backyard to find out. You know, no pressure.
我们会亲自在利兹的后院聚在一起找出答案。你知道，没压力。
Since Ernie is a lot more normal than we are, after he accepts the invitation to come and meet all of us, Liz and I agree we need to get our curb appeal together, just a light retouching of a few family dramas, just price out some smoke and a few mirrors. I mean, should we say mom died of alcoholism in a West Village [BLEEP] with mice running around? Or should we just say she was a rich girl from St. Louis, who was a champion equestrian and debutante?
既然恩尼比我们正常得多，在他接受邀请来见我们所有人之后，利兹和我同意我们需要整理好我们的门面，只是对一些家庭戏剧进行轻微的润色，只是给一些烟雾和几个镜子标个价。我是说，我们应该说妈妈死于酒精中毒，住在一个有老鼠跑来跑去的西村[哔]里吗？还是我们应该说她是个来自圣路易斯的富家女孩，是冠军马术家和名媛？
And do we mention that Amy married a Tunisian man and took off to his family's farm in Tunisia and didn't speak to any of us for eight years but is now back and never really explained any of this to us? The real worry though is, of course, my father. How do we prevent Ernie from seeing that while my father is the ideal person to sit next to at a bar-- funny, a million stories, a truly entertaining charismatic man-- those aren't the most important qualities in a father? He's painfully unaware of other people's needs and feelings.
我们提到艾米嫁给了一个突尼斯男人并带着他去了他家在突尼斯的农场，八年没和我们说话，但现在回来了，也从未真正向我们解释过这些吗？真正的担心当然是我父亲。我们如何阻止恩尼看到，虽然爸爸是酒吧里最理想的谈话对象——有趣、有百万个故事、一个真正有趣又有魅力的人——但这些不是父亲身上最重要的品质。他对别人的需求和感受毫无察觉。
And when you really do need him, he's just not able to be there for you in the way that you want him to be. Like, when my mother died of a stroke after years of really grim alcoholism, he offered no words of comfort, but instead asked me what we should do with the bloody couch that she died on. Should I go over to mama's and take that bloody couch out of view so you girls don't have to see it? Although, where the hell am I going to drag a bloody couch? I'll probably get arrested.
当你真正需要他时，他就是没法以你想要的方式陪伴你。比如，我母亲在多年的痛苦酗酒后死于中风时，他没有提供任何安慰的话，而是问我我们应该怎么处理她死在上面的那张该死的沙发？我要不要去妈妈那里把那张该死的沙发从视线中移走，这样你们女孩就不必看到了？虽然，我到底要把那张该死的沙发拖到哪里去？我可能会被逮捕。
Is seeing that bloody couch going to traumatize you girls, do you think? When I tried to get him to talk about what he was feeling or take some interest in what I was feeling, he wasn't mean about it. He's not a mean person. It's more like he just can't do it, like he'd gently reroute the conversation in a different direction.
看到那张该死的沙发会创伤你们女孩吗，你们觉得？当我试图让他谈论他的感受或对我的感受产生兴趣时，他并不刻薄。他不是个刻薄的人。更像是他根本做不到，就像他会温柔地把谈话引向另一个方向。
Get him on the phone, and within two minutes, he launches into a steroid-fueled monologue about his obsession with the beginnings of the neocon movement or with Russian ballerina Diana Vishneyva. And once he's off and running, there's no interrupting him. You just wander in and out of the room with him on speaker, doing your laundry, making dinner, because he can go on forever. You just have to make a decision about when you can no longer go on.
通过电话打给他，两分钟之内，他就启动了一段关于他迷恋新保守主义运动的开始或者是迷恋俄罗斯芭蕾舞演员戴安娜·维什涅娃的类固醇驱动的独白。一旦他开始，就没人能打断他。你只是对他开着免提在他房间里进进出出，洗衣服，做饭，因为他可以永远讲下去。你只是得决定你什么时候不能再继续了。
And so I guess I'm worried about Ernie's big day. The day of the party was extremely humid and buggy in my sister's backyard in Brooklyn. And rain threatened to force us inside, where it would be very cramped.
所以我猜我在担心恩尼的大日子。派对当天，我在布鲁克林我姐姐的后院，天气非常潮湿且有很多虫子。雨威胁要迫使我们进去，那里会非常挤。
Seeing my father next to Ernie for the first time was mind-bending they looked so much alike. After some hugs and pictures, we all sit at the long outside table. I'm welling up. I can't imagine how emotional this must be for Ernie. His wife Donna is squeezing his hand in support.
第一次看到父亲和恩尼站在一起真是不可思议，他们长得太像了。经过一些拥抱和照片，我们都坐在长长的外桌旁。我热泪盈眶。我无法想象这对恩尼来说一定多么情绪化。他的妻子唐娜正在紧紧握住他的手以示支持。
I look around the table and wonder, why is Ernie not sitting next to my dad? Shouldn't my dad have said, Ernie, sit next to me? It's like he forgets he's the dad.
我环顾餐桌，心想，为什么恩尼没有坐在爸爸旁边？爸爸不应该说，恩尼，坐在我旁边吗？就像他忘记了他是爸爸。
But very quickly, we all get talking and laughing. And Ernie gives my dad a picture of Raqui for his birthday. And it feels like the whole thing is going great. Then the rain comes down, and we hustle inside, and we're fumbling to get back to that initial connection.
但很快，我们都开始谈话大笑。恩尼给爸爸一份拉奎尔的照片作为生日礼物。感觉这一切进行得非常棒。然后大雨倾盆，我们匆忙跑进去，我们在试图回到最初的联系中笨手笨脚。
Then the rain stops. And we're back in the yard, eating, drinking. Down the table, I see my father, now sitting next to Ernie. But Ernie hasn't said anything for a really long time. So I know my dad is definitely talking about F. Scott Fitzgerald and his theory that Fitzgerald forced his wife Zelda to have an abortion at the Plaza Hotel in 1922, a topic which has dominated our lives for decades. For as long as I can remember, it's the number one thing he uses to avoid talking about anything real.
然后雨停了。我们回到院子里，吃着、喝着。在桌子的那一头，我看到父亲现在坐在恩尼旁边。但恩尼已经很长时间没说话了。所以我知道爸爸绝对是在谈论F·斯科特·菲茨杰拉德和他关于菲茨杰拉德在1922年在广场酒店强迫妻子塞尔达流产的理论，这个话题占据了我们几十年的生活。只要我记得，这就是他用来避免谈论任何真实事情的头号事情。
When my son was four weeks old, and my husband and I were about to move to California, he said he was stopping by with a present for the baby, which turned out to be some Stilton from Murray's Cheese shop. And as I hobbled around post c-section, packing our suitcases and breastfeeding the baby, completely about to fall apart, he nibbled on the blue cheese and talked about Zelda Fitzgerald's abortion and its aftermath.
当我儿子四周大时，我丈夫和我要搬去加利福尼亚，他说他要过来给婴儿送个礼物，结果是从默里奶酪店带的一些斯蒂尔顿奶酪。当我剖腹产后跛着脚，收拾行李和母乳喂养孩子，完全快要崩溃时，他嚼着蓝色奶酪，谈论着塞尔达·菲茨杰拉德的堕胎及其余波。
Liz and I had strategized before the party that if he got on Fitzgerald, we would cut him off before it could get going. But it's too late now. I'm horrified, because I don't think my dad has asked Ernie anything about him.
利兹和我在派对前制定了策略，如果他谈论菲茨杰拉德，我们就会在他开始之前切断他。但现在已经太晚了。我很恐惧，因为我不觉得爸爸问过恩尼任何关于他的事情。
Does he honestly have zero curiosity about this person, this child whom he almost missed entirely? Ernie looks bewildered and heartbroken. Watching a 62-year-old man get crushed right in front of me, watching him wait patiently to be seen by a man whose eyes are looking elsewhere, it was like watching my spirit get crushed, like a reenactment.
他真的对这个人、这个孩子一点好奇心都没有吗，他差点完全错过的孩子？恩尼看起来困惑又心碎。看着一个62岁的男人就在我面前被粉碎，看着他耐心等待着被一个眼睛看向别处的男人所看见，这就像看着我的灵魂被粉碎，就像一次重演。
My father produces a fountain pen that Raqui gave him. It's engraved with his initials. Ernest looks really excited. But my father isn't saying, this is for you Ernest. I want you to have this.
父亲拿出了拉奎尔给他的钢笔。上面刻着他的名字首字母。恩尼看起来非常兴奋。但父亲没有说，这是给你的恩尼。我想要你拥有这个。
We all wait for him to say that. But instead, he says, now, should I hang on to this and give it to you later or now? I yell, now, Dad. The metal tip is slightly bent. It doesn't work. But you have to hand it to my dad for simply not losing it for over half a century.
我们都在等他那样说。但他反而说，现在，我是应该留着它还是以后给你？我大喊，现在，爸爸。金属尖稍微有点弯。它没法用。但你不得不佩服我爸爸只是没把它弄丢了半个多世纪。
He gives it to Ernie. Ernie looks thrilled and says, I know a guy in New Orleans who can fix it.
他把它给了恩尼。恩尼看起来很激动说，我知道纽奥良有个家伙能修好它。
In my post-mortem with my dad a few days later, he talks about the food, about my niece's pretty dress, talks about all kinds of things. But I have to push him really hard to say anything about meeting his son. I'm practically mugging him for an emotion.
几天后在我和爸爸的“验尸”谈话中，他谈到了食物，谈到了我侄女漂亮的裙子，谈到了各种事情。但我不得不强迫他去说任何关于遇见他儿子的事情。我简直是在向他抢劫一种情绪。
Finally he says, I think I'll have a great relationship with Ernie. And I thank you very much for that, Jean-Joe, for bringing us together. So much for my dream of Ernie transforming us into a more loving family.
最后他说，我想我会和恩尼建立伟大的关系。我非常感谢你做这些，让-乔，把我们聚在一起。这就是我梦想恩尼把我们变成更相亲相爱的家庭的结局。
Let's be honest. My family is like a long-running production of The Fantasticks, where all the actors are too old for the characters they're playing and the lighting people miss a third of the cues. But now, there's this one fresh faced kid just out of drama school who brings down the house in every scene.
老实说。我的家庭就像长久上演的《幻想曲》，所有演员对于他们扮演的角色都太老了，灯光师错过了三分之一的提示。但现在，有个刚从戏剧学院出来的清新脸孔的孩子在每一场戏里都赢得了满堂彩。
Ernie sends an email after the party where he describes our family as, having a bond I truly admire, and that he felt included in a way that felt genuine and from the heart. Wow, Liz says, we really put on a hell of a show. And then Liz and I have a Zoom with Ernie, Ernest, Ernest Enrique Svenson.
恩尼在派对后发了一封邮件，他形容我们的家庭是，“有着一种我真正钦佩的纽带”，而且他感到一种发自内心、真实的方式被包容。哇，利兹说，我们真的上演了一场精彩的表演。然后利兹和我就和恩尼，恩尼斯特，恩尼斯特·恩里克·斯文森进行了Zoom。
Steve sent me something after the weekend, he says. What, we ask? 117 page transcript of Zelda and F. Scott's therapy sessions that Steve hand copied at the Princeton archives. Have you seen it, he asks?
周末后史蒂夫寄给我一些东西，他说。什么，我们问？117页的塞尔达和F·斯科特的治疗会议笔录，史蒂夫在普林斯顿档案馆手抄的。你见过了吗，他问？
Oh, Ernie, have we seen it? Yes, we have, we say, not sure how much to give away. He's got a long road ahead. And he's got to walk it just like we did. It's pretty interesting, Ernie says. Yeah, we say, yeah, it is.
哦，恩尼，我们见过吗？是的，我们见过，我们说，不确定要透露多少。他还有很长的路要走。而且他必须像我们一样走过它。这很有趣，恩尼说。是的，我们说，是的，很有趣。
Jeanne Darst, she's currently developing her book, Fiction Ruined My Family for television.
让·达斯特，她目前正在为电视开发她的书《小说毁了我的家庭》。
[MUSIC - MARIAN BURNS, "COMMUNICATION SONG (SONG FOR KIDS)"]
[音乐 - 玛丽安·伯恩斯，《沟通之歌（儿童之歌）》]
Well, our program was produced today by Lina Misitzis. The people who put together today's program include Bim Adewunmi, Elna Baker, Susan Burton, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Aviva DeKornfeld, Rudy Lee, Tobin Low, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Alix Spiegel, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Laura Starcheski, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, Chloee Weiner, and Diane Wu.
好了，我们的节目今天由莉娜·米西齐斯制作。把今天节目组合在一起的人包括比姆·阿德武米、埃尔娜·贝克、苏珊·伯顿、达娜·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德、鲁迪·李、托宾·洛、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、罗宾·塞门、阿丽莎·希普、劳拉·斯塔切斯基、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、朱莉·惠特克、克洛伊·维纳和黛安·吴。
Our managing editor, Sarah Abdurrahman. Our Senior Editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special Thanks today to Alison O'Connor, Jesse David Fox, David Iserson, Chloe Ifshin, Jamie Loftus, Zach Zimmerman, and Guns N' Roses.
我们的执行主编，萨拉·阿卜杜勒拉赫曼。我们的高级编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。今天特别感谢艾莉森·奥康纳、杰西·大卫·福克斯、大卫·伊瑟森、克洛伊·伊夫辛、杰米·洛夫图斯、扎克·齐默尔曼和枪与玫瑰乐队。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 750 episodes for absolutely free. Also, we have videos there. We have lists of favorite shows. We have tons of other stuff.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费流媒体播放我们超过750集的档案。此外，我们还有那里的视频。我们有最喜欢的节目清单。我们还有很多其他东西。
Again, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always, for a program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia.
再次重申，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交换，交付给公共广播电台。一如既往，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。
You know, when I applied for this job way back when, I walked into his office, shook his hand, told him my radio name at the time, Bugseyyyy Leroi. He looked at my resume, looked at me, looked at my resume, then back at me. And said--
你知道，当初我申请这份工作时，我走进他的办公室，握了他的手，告诉他我当时的广播名字，Bugseyyyy Leroi。他看了看我的简历，看了看我，看了看我的简历，然后又看回我。并说——
Don't do that. Don't spend the whole interview not being yourself.
别那样。别花整个采访时间不做自己。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。